it's gonna come down to shock see he's
gonna get caught in the corner though
get some running shot on the deal get
the second one sucks he's making it
happen a fire but oxy oxy is Kenny first
up the back he finds a shot but he's
being printed up close he need shots to
support him he's working for a playful
what it's go off oh my god Kenny this
should be impossible from the way that's
a nice flick though but still with the
tenth second he's got a fight Hobbit off
to the left
Oh what is that flick for Drake it lands
the first shot and he's fully aware the
officer weapon that elicits many
different kinds of motions to counter
strike fans with its ability to do a
one-shot kill with a shot to the head or
the torso it can be frustrating to play
against but thrilling to see in the
hands of an expert
Kenny has stuck in the sight finding
mole that's brilliant if Kenny has again
up close oh my goodness
the noscope on the 3rd this guy's
absolutely insane cold zeroes quicker
gets a second as well as the ball will
go down and follows it up through all
lining up cool with the iconic and
devastating weapon has been tweaked and
balanced in every version of CS
but csgo the version of the gun ended up
being so powerful that it was hit with
one of the most drastic balanced changes
in the series history I was a damn why
did it do that that's also for me
because I actually because of this
competitive players from both CS 1.6 and
source were forced to adapt to a whole
new game when csgo came out in April
2012 and over time some of the best
offers developed a new exciting kinetic
style that saw them play more up close
and aggressive we've seen a high rise in
the aggressive peeking offing styles in
the past half a year or so due to
superstars like Kenny S + JW making good
use of it Kenny s maybe the most famous
offer ever was a great example of this
he developed a fast-paced mobile style
and he wasn't afraid to challenge his
enemies up close Kenny he thrived in
close quarters offing teams changed
completely changed how they played the
game just because of one player because
of Kenny that's how scarily good he was
but on March 31st 2015 valve released an
update to csgo that drastically altered
the off in the patch released on the
31st of March the OL and/or snipers as
well but they're not particularly
relevant in the comparison but the alt
was nerfed in as much as movement while
scoped was reduced to explain what's
going on here when scoped you now have a
very slow acceleration when running in
fact when shift walking you immediately
start at your max walk speed making it
faster to start shift walking than
running the optimal scoped movement then
that the off would be tapping shift to
get going it all feels really awkward
the immediate and continued impact of
this change is difficult to emphasize it
was so dramatic and its timing right
before April Fool's made some think that
it was a joke but two players like Kenny
ass
it was no laughing matter I got hits
like even about motivation
I was like they have why did it do that
that's so unfair for me because I
actually felt like they did it for me
they did it because of me that's not
necessarily true but that's how I felt
once it became clear that the change
wasn't a joke and bad taste
the community began to process the full
extent of the nerve and the reaction was
mixed and not only has this lowered
scope movement nerfed certain Pro
aspects and certain players in in in
quite a destructive manner
it shows how out of touch valve is with
the pro scene at the time the off would
dictate games now it's still relevant in
games but you can you can utilize it
differently
well the nerve hurt anyone who had an OP
it disproportionally affected Teesside
offers who are more often peeking to
find their kills the slower movement
speed gave defending offers particularly
those holding angles more time to react
and meant that any team that relied
heavily on offers suffered the problem
was before that like a dog could just PQ
and not have an angle held to just wreck
you because you wouldn't even with an 8k
unless you had a perfect shot you
wouldn't have time now it's a little
more difficult for them to do that it
also meant that Kenny s is explosive
high movement play style was hampered
remember like at the beginning of the
date I was like I was speaking it was so
slow that I was speaking and I was
shooting the war and I was dying
straight afterwards
what happened unfortunately I think for
him is that he just he lost the
confidence right the OP knife came in
that complete and he because he was so
mobile because he was such a dynamic
oper him and JW both got hit the hardest
I think by this op nerf because it just
felt like he got gutted right when he
was coming into his prime when he could
have been God and just taken over
everything
the game was changed and then I think
that really impacted his confidence
but for some high-profile offers like
Guardian who tended to move less and
hold more angles the nerve had less of
an impact I can I can't play anything my
leaders for me before I became to to
Navi for example a super aggressive way
I could rush anywhere we go up and I
came to Navi just made me super passio
especially decides to to old angles and
be actually a good city sniper in the
end operas only had one choice adapt and
while more stationary offers didn't miss
a beat it took Kenny a while to
rediscover his form the immediate result
was certainly Kenny a little bit
guardian but certainly Kenny was hurt
the most as I talked about he was
someone who could play very close he
could move very quickly with the OP he
could hit no scopes he was constantly
quick peeking and quick scoping that
movement mechanic was taken out quite
significantly and it's not that Kenny
wasn't skillful enough at the time to
say oh it's different I could you know
I'm still good with it it wasn't it
didn't have the skill suddenly it was
that it's it's muscle memory and it's
force of habit it there was a lot of
things I was doing and I could not do
anymore
so I had to find you stuff I had to to
play a bit different so yeah it was
super hard for me at the beginning like
maybe do free first month where like
hell for me well the changes made over
three years ago the nerf remains a
subject of some debate the heart of the
question is this how much impact should
one player with a specialist weapon
really have on the game and doesn't make
sense to nerf a weapon that only one in
five players use if there were only a
couple of offers that can really push
the gun to its absolute limit you
remember before the did they'd be up
they could like there was stuff too much
yeah one guy so what's my up side
la TARTA views
outside small expensive pans outside
well sir kilowatts worst oxide no no I
don't have redundant vile but it's I
think there's nothing I think he gave
you with you is there some alternate
universe where the off was never an
earth and everyone started using it like
Kenny ass maybe it did that nerve would
still be turbulence more than I am right
now I would say because before the DEF I
was 42 minutes out of the office you
were thinking about me a mostly G W as
well because GW is also like GW campsite
is quite similar to mine so yeah I think
people would have that take us as as as
biggest examples and and yeah I think
nowadays it would be like the the boss
come on Jeff style obviously this is all
hypothetical
since valves changes stuck but for now
for better or for worse the optin URF is
here to stay
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]